welcome back to new rock stars eric voss
has been apprehended by the tva we found
out he was a variant that split through
time so that he could ride the pirates
of the caribbean ride
over and over and over again but don't
worry he's been apprehended and killed
loki episode 3 revealed that the evil
space lizards of the tva
have not only been lying to us but
they've been lying to their own
employees can you not even trust your
bosses anymore it's almost like they
don't have our best interests in mind
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitch the wildest theories i'm your host
tommy bechtolden going rogue with me
today
host of the film philosopher's podcast
eddie villanueva
what is up tommy it is good to see you
hosting and
in the chair and no longer eric there
and i'm trying not to rhyme but
it's great to be here guys i like when
you rhyme everyone knows that that's
that's a passion of mine uh
i'll start beatboxing you can all agree
yes please speaking of which streamer
extraordinaire angelica petraeu is with
us
wait wait are we all be boxing no i
don't know i i don't think we should uh
but i find if we want to try
this show is all about trying new things
this is rogue theory maybe we don't even
do rogue theories today maybe we all
just get personal
talk about what's going on in our lives
i'm in a hot garage right now
anyway the third panelist we have
co-writer of the hellbent
comic that you can support on
kickstarter and don't worry baby we will
explain to you
how to support this on kickstarter
friend of the show dj wooldridge hello
dj
hey how's it going yeah
hellbentcomicbook.com thank you thank
you thank you for having me i'm so
excited to be here yo we are excited to
have you guys
okay topic one why are the time keepers
lying
episode three of loki revealed that
everyone who works for the tva is
in fact actually a past variant why did
the timekeepers propaganda say that they
created all of these agents
and assuming they're powerful enough to
trap these variants
into servitude and wipe their memories
why are they not powerful enough to
create their own workforce
and what else are these space lizards
lying about i think that's a really
great reveal in the last episode if you
haven't watched it and then why are you
seeing this episode here
um but it was a great reveal to find out
that they're actual people because now
everything else prior to that makes
sense in terms of all the material of
like oh
you're a variant so instead of like okay
you're a variant you're going to go get
judged and pruned it was like oh there
was
like pieces of material throughout the
end credits and so forth
but i i think the biggest thing to kind
of go off of for
this reveal is the fact that are there
actually
time keepers like are there actual
people who are
pulling those strings or is it just kind
of a shell of a
of a you know mirage of some sort
of oz situation yeah exactly pay no
attention to the naked man behind the
curtain you know they're too
serious yeah i would also like to throw
out i would also like to throw out the
idea the possibility
that the timekeepers are actually
variants of loki oh
[Music]
all of them all of them they're three
different loki variants
because i think it's either there's
nobody there like you find them and
they're just like corpses on thrones or
uh we find out that they're all variants
of local because if you've got a loki
show
and you've introduced multiple versions
of loki how do you not have
evil loki's running around yes right so
so we've established the tva is a lie
everything's a lie
um confirmed mobius had a jet ski in his
past life
and i hope i hope that he gets his hands
on one later and goes wow
um but but yeah i think i'm thinking
now wow that there's too
much mystery shrouded around these time
keepers and i definitely
think that it's probably like old man
loki or something because who's to say
if so many loki's over time
time subjectively um have been trying to
take control of the tva
who's to say one hasn't already yeah or
or let's just snow piercer all over
again kind of thing
yeah or we could like combine all the
theories and the time keepers are
mephisto
reed richards and magneto oh my god
wait what if what if it's doctor dude
my favorite theory there you go what if
it's cosmos
what if it's just three dc characters no
kang the conqueror no
he's going to be in uh ant-man
quantomanium right quantum machine
hero heroes don't do that heroes don't
do that okay tommy
all right fine heroes it can't be batman
at least
perfect perfect all right so so we so we
what else do we think that they might be
lying about we think this whole thing
might be a ruse this might just be loki
land
where loki has just created all of uh
all of the tva in order to trap himself
in other versions of himself
is there like is this like a highlander
situation where in the end
there can only be one loki and also does
this mean that the loki that was killed
by thanos
is not actually dead what are we saying
i think it'd be some i was talking about
this with uh with my buddy ed greer i
think it's one of those that like
if it is loki's they've created the
situation and so that's why they're so
hell-bent on
on pruning other loki's because every
time one finds out they have to join
the timekeepers and it's like no we need
to be the ones
or again maybe they're all dead and they
don't exist who knows it's a
schrodinger's loki
so i i i really want to see how
they're going to like keep because
obviously like we've established it's a
lie
there's something behind everything
that's going on there what i'm wondering
is if it has to do with the possibility
of the theory that
um the tva and the city it's in
is located within the quantum realm you
know maybe
somebody who's trying to protect the
location and
the i guess city therein
of the tva from getting found out and
thereby
exploiting like the loophole that
they're in of where
time moves differently there um
because we honestly can probably truly
put 100 money on that the fact that
there's probably nobody running the show
there's probably somebody who's secretly
behind the scenes
but uh yeah i want i'm wondering if
maybe it has to do with
that city that ant-man you know goes by
in the first ant-man film when he's
shrinking down the molecular level
if that could possibly be where the tva
is located and that has to do with the
overall
secret oh i like that i like that so
even the location is a lie
the realm it's in everything's just
shrouded in mystery here
okay that's all you know thank goodness
we have three episodes left because
nothing drives me crazier
than when a show goes like right at the
end
everything this show has been about is
not true yeah
yeah it was all a dream yeah exactly
it was all in a snow globe we're gonna
dallas the crap out of this
exactly wake up fresh out of the shower
there he is thor chris hemsworth and
he's cut he's not gone
he's not uh thick thor anymore he's just
regular cut thor
did he ever lose it or was it movie
magic we don't know we've got a lot more
theories to discuss here
especially about a character who was not
in this episode of loki but was in the
news anyway but first
a few words from the folks that help us
make rogue theory
first things first over at new rockstars
merch we've unveiled
out of time buying our latest obsession
shirt will give you the ability to leave
a message on our inside marvel
loki after show with either a shout out
or your own road theory
or a threat to eric i don't know it's
the internet he gets threatened all the
time
don't actually do that now i'm gonna get
a text from eric saying please stop
provoking the fans to threaten me if
you're gonna threaten anyone threaten
philip he's the most in shape
he can defend himself and it'll show up
on screen during the show by the way
we've got a full line of loki inspired
merch including our augmented reality
shirt because real reality is too hard
to deal with you need a t-shirt
that takes you to a far away fantasy
land miss minutes stickers
so adorable tva buttons and other cool
stuff
that hasn't even been released yet find
it all over at newrockstarsmerch.com
owning a truck is great because you can
all a lot of stuff what's not so great
is keeping that stuff organized and out
of the elements
you got your tools rattling around under
the seat or grandma's priceless antique
spoons
just sitting there in the sun and rain
in the truck bed and god knows spoons
they're not meant to be outdoors unless
they're camping spoons
you gotta have indoor spoons if you want
to eat soup guys that's why you've got
to get
decked drawer systems for your truck get
decked
that makes organizing accessing
protecting everything you need
so much easier each of decks two full
bed length drawers
can carry up to 200 pounds of whatever
you got so you want a mirror you want to
murder a set of stocky twins
you can put both their bodies in your
decks carry them in your truck
the drawers roll out waist high giving
you easy access to all your stuff
the drawers are weatherproof protecting
your stuff from the elements
and theft in case it's weather wizard
trying to steal things because of the
way the system sits in your truck
if your tailgate is locked you can't
open the drawers and all your stuff is
secure
the jet drawer system is 100 made in the
usa
backed by a three-year no hassle
warranty in the fourth year
we do guarantee you will be hassled
unfortunately but for three years
you will live your life hassle-free and
without worry
and a second-to-none customer service
team ready to answer all your questions
i spoke with a man named bill he came
over to my house and he just cuddled me
while i was scared during a thunderstorm
these guys are very thorough
and gentle get your deck drawer system
and quit letting grandma's spoons rattle
around by going to deck.com
rogue where you'll get free shipping
that's decked.com
rogue for free shipping on your decked
drawer system
duck.com slash rogue so masculine
but also fun it's finally summer ah
summer and we're actually going to be
able to do stuff this year
if you want to not me i'm still staying
inside i'm an indoor cat baby
i'm talking barbecues no thanks theme
parks no way
casual strolls down the boardwalk maybe
i don't know i'm back on bumble we'll
see what happens
and that's where faraday comes in they
make perfect clothes for the summer
parody is a family run brand making high
quality timeless clothing while still
fighting about
who gets the last drumstick at the
dinner table they also have a modern
design
and functionality that got the perfect
summer clothes that are comfortable
stylish and they fit great a few members
of our own new rockstars family have
really been digging the shirts from
ferrari
off-screen producer zach loves the short
sleeve knit session shirt
and if you think eric voss isn't going
full parrothead
in the kona shirt then you've never
eaten a cheeseburger in paradise my
friend and eric hasn't been eating many
cheeseburgers lately
because we've been tortured through a
fitness show ah
deep cut to another thing they're so
confident in the quality of the shirt
they have a lifetime guarantee of
quality
they'll replace or fix your clothes
forever unless you're a variant in which
case
the guarantee is over because you broke
the time rules no matter what
and to top it off faraday is giving
rogue theory audiences 20
off whoa what a bargain all right so
listen to me if you trust one thing i
tell you
stock up on all your clothes for summer
now we don't know if there's gonna be a
closed shortage
head over to the faradaybrand.com and
use code rogue at checkout
to snag 20 off all your summer gear
that's code rogue
at ferrity t f-a-h-e-r-t-y
brand dot com for twenty percent off
our dear friends and saviors at baluchi
have a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis but in chewable
form and at a fraction of the cost blue
chew is an online prescription service
so no doctor's office
or pharmacy trips it shifts right to
your door in a discrete package but like
i always say
you put my name right on the cover and
you say population
one boner town one hard on street
tommy bechdel these are for him he's not
ashamed you sign up at bluetooth.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers
and once you're approved you receive
your prescription within days you don't
have to wait long their licensed medical
providers work with you to find the
right ingredient in strength
you hate swallowing pills great news
like i said blue chew is chewable just
like it says in the name if you thought
it was blue chew because there was some
other reason
you're into some kinky stuff that they
still have on pornhub so
uh don't by the way never put you in the
search bar in pornhub it's not going to
work out no matter what you're into
so if you could benefit for some extra
confidence from some extra confidence
when it's time to perform
visit bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information
now we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free
when you use promo code rogue at
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
if you can't pay five dollars for an
erection you don't deserve to have sex
in this economy
that's bluetooth.com promo code rogue to
receive your first month free
we thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
podcast god bless you blue chew god
bless us everyone topic number two we're
going to talk about
mt's crush a lady that's been all on all
of our minds lately
miss minutes ms minute's hidden
backstory miss minutes voice actor
and former new rock stars guest tara
strong revealed in an interview that
there's a lot more to be revealed
about miss minutes you don't really know
who she is
what she is where she is what her origin
story is how sentient she is if she's uh
has a horse in this race at all
and what her intentions are so i want to
ask you guys right now
what is miss minute's deal well okay
there's a lot of
of theories and approaches i can take to
this but
the first thing that popped into my head
is
because i don't actually think lady loki
loki's lady loki
because she was claiming to be sylvia
and i don't think mcu is going to do
mashups like this
so i think that something's going to
to go down where like maybe miss minutes
is actually lady loki
and is a loki variant and is
being cursed yeah so that's
my initial theory and that's what i want
because like sylvie is
you know branching from sylvie lush and
his enchantress
and so i feel like the true lady loki
could be miss
minutes and because lady loki was maybe
so powerful
they had to turn her into a really cute
little oh my god
i love that so that would kind of
explain why sylvie is so
like she gets so like don't call me loki
whenever it happens but she's also like
coily not trying to pretend that she
isn't like she obviously she put the
costume on
but yeah like yeah oh i like that i
think
by the end of this episode we're going
to have convinced ourselves that
literally everybody at the tva
is is a low-key mobius loki oh yeah
boy from the good place he's a loki
yeah he's a loki they're all loki's
they're all variants
i i think i think that's i really like
that idea
in terms of the fact of how how
saturated this show is going to be with
loki personnel um another
perspective i'm thinking is that miss
minutes could possibly be
kind of the inside person for
for whoever it is that we kind of come
to find out
is running the tva she's not just an inf
in information kind of sentient teacher
but is actually somebody who's reporting
back even the the eyes for
whoever is running the tva and mind you
when we figure that out
we have thoughts and ideas thus far but
right i i really feel like
we're gonna get a bigger glimpse in the
next episode of exactly her role
and finally kind of see as to her being
more of a bigger
tool in not in the negative connotations
in terms of the bigger tool for
whoever's running the
tva uh or who knows maybe you know
tara strong she's really great to see
what her whole
impact is she's basically an
interdimensional alexa
she's interdimensional alexa like you're
saying whatever you want her but papa
bezos is listening
exactly and he's going
if we actually in this episode figure
out yeah
involvement in in the mcu without eric
being on it
they're gonna have to scrub this from
the internet eric mephisto
is jeff
and there's no coincidence that miss
minutes has so many m's in it
and mephisto also starts i feel like
is there any is there any chance that
like
this doesn't mean anything like because
i know when i write stuff
like i'll have like a throwaway
character but i'll still have like a
page i'll have like a page of like
so i know when the actor knows whoever
knows who this character is
and so she could be like yeah there's a
lot about miss minutes you don't know
which is objectively true but it's not
like
we're going to find out or it matters to
the show and if
we're following the same train of
thought if we're following the same
train of thought that what
that happened with wandavision i mean
paul bettany did the same exact thing
and was like oh i'm gonna have this
really great scene in the last episode
and it's gonna be with this person i've
always wanted to act with
and we of course as nerds and and and
rogue theorists
we love to let our minds go wild as to
who that could have been
i had money on a al pacino kind of yeah
wasn't it gonna be al pacino yeah i was
like i thought al pacino was gonna show
up
so there's a very big chance that you're
right
this is probably going to turn into
something where it's like a goose chase
and we find out oh miss minutes is no
longer in the rest of the series
after episode three but where's the fun
in that
yeah here's the problem i have with that
is now
you are calling tara strong a liar
i'm i'm saying we're misinterpreting
what she's saying because sarah said
miss minutes is more
she's supposed to i mean correct me if
i'm wrong the quote is there's more to
her than we know about
which could be true and also not pertain
to the show at all yeah it also could be
like a spin-off comic like one shot
comic they're getting released
loki miss minutes miss minutes kills the
marvel universe
they could do like the whole promotion
of like the tva
manual or something with miss minutes in
each page talking about
how to operate as a variant once once it
comes out as to
the whole tva is actually filled with
variants rather than actual
original created people from the
timekeepers which
by the way there's no way there's no way
that they're not taking like miss
minutes and like that opening sequence
with the tva the line and they're not
like working on
an avengers campus ride with the tva
it's 100 at least whether we see the
light of day or not they're working on
it
for sure and i guess the question on all
of our minds is there a mr minutes
or and if there is he definitely took
her last name when they got married
his last name was like very progressive
something like that it's very
progressive
uh exactly hey or miss minutes right
or another missed minutes two minutes
minutes because if miss minutes
oh the more the merrier because if if
miss minutes
is a low-key variant then you know she
could be
also bi that's true happy pride gender
fluid
pride month miss minutes gender fluid
happy pride month loki
yeah they they marvel marvel vaguely
touched on that maybe one of the
characters
that's it i feel like that's as much as
disney will let it happen it's like
okay i mean yeah they're cool i guess
yeah yeah
just that's as much as we get it's like
okay i want to see
loki make out with a dude make it happen
they've come a long way
baby steps for sure maybe not the big
steps that we need but i appreciate
the slightest baby steps it's time now
for our road question
this is a question that was so broke it
couldn't even make the regular part of
the show
now now it's just now it's just the
wheels are off guys don't
be untethered before you were all being
so
guarded about your opinions really not
revealing yourselves and this question
i want you to come out of your shells
like the cicadas that are tormenting the
earth right now
tommy's going to lift his shirt and say
what do you guys think of this growth
just yes guys tell me about these moles
you want to hear the story of how i got
these moles uh okay
it was reported that harrison ford
injured his shoulder on the set of
indiana jones five
michael's personal friend harrison ford
you know what he means to me
well we wish him a speedy recovery
what's the most
indiana jones way to injure yourself
snake bite
yeah he hates snakes this is all the
snake fights that has to be like one of
the most
on the nose types of things in my mind
mind you that's me personally
is if indiana jones gets bit by snake
the only person who i know hates snakes
more than
indiana jones is uh well i think now
thor because he got attacked by loki
when he was younger but
you know when he turned into a snake um
but i i think
getting bit by a snake might be the way
for me i'm thinking
i'm thinking it was a strategic shoulder
roll
under a collapsing uh temple of some
sort
ah okay right or a door shutting yeah he
didn't get his hat in time and just
didn't pull it fast enough i'm thinking
with harrison ford's age
you know like uh a piece of fruit or
something fell
just a little bit too far out of reach
yeah because there's no way they let him
within a mile of any stunts like that's
just not
yeah that's either that or he was flying
someplace and we're not hearing about
the
fiery crash around the soldier shoulder
injury
yeah i was gonna say if it wasn't on the
golf course it wasn't harrison ford so
he he injured his shoulder and 74 people
are dead
but we're not hearing about those
because uh because they want to talk
about the shoulder injury phrase
i think obviously it would be crushed by
a rolling boulder ah
that would be uh that would be the most
indiana jones way to die
guys uh they told me according to the
script that i have to declare a winner
but let me tell you when i look out at
this panel
i see three winners and uh and then me
but i'm going to declare all three of
you the winners today congratulations
you're all winners in my hearts
you all did a fantastic job bringing joy
to the nerd galaxy that's it for this
episode of rogue theory
thanks to our guests angelica train
eddie villanueva and dj wooldridge
support our channel by checking out that
new loki themed
merch at newrockstars.com make sure you
support dj's uh
comic book dj want to tell us again how
we can uh support that
yeah go to hellbentcomicbook.com it's a
crazy awesome supernatural adventure if
you're a fan of like
the classic vertigo comics like preacher
and sandman you're gonna love
hellbent so hellbentcomicbook.com go
check it out i've got amazing
collaborators uh we've got cool variant
covers
a ton of cool stuff so go check it out
hellbentcomicbook.com i'll be there so
don't forget newrockstarsmerch.com
follow
me tommy bechtold follow new rockstar
subscribe here on youtube
and we will see you next time on rogue
theory bye
[Music]
you